[Applaudissements]
tu m'as volé Freddy
c'est quoi le plan mec et j'ai le pognon
papa alors comme ça tu es dans la merde
j'ai pris une balle en gros je suis le
seul à pouvoir t'aider c'est bien ça
j'arrive dans combien de temps
il faut que tu reviennes tu as fait une
grosse erreur
il faut que j'apporte cet argent à ma
fille
[Musique]
ils ont déjà eu
ne va pas suffire
tu as perdu beaucoup de sang
si tu es un gangster tu fais quoi dans
ce puce c'est pas ce que j'avais
envisagé tu es quoi tu sauras bientôt ce
que je veux on a un problème toi et moi
je connais un gars au bar
il est d'accord de nous conduire on doit
aller
allons faire ton truc à la con
s'il te plaît et ramène le mois ici
il me suive
maintenant tu réponds plus au téléphone
tu t'arrêtes pas en route
je vais être très gentil merde
il faut que tu reviennes autrement
ils veulent du sang